[Music]
this is the playground of the rich and
famous st. Moritz and Switzerland
located in the heart of the Alps here
luxury meets the international jet set
but the traditional side of Switzerland
is also evident as with the 12th century
leaning tower of the saint mauritius
church modern structures like this
apartment building by british architect
Norman Foster
are also making their mark st. Moritz is
mostly known as a winter sports
destination but summer time has lots to
offer tourists as well especially those
wanting a bit of an adventure pads that
are normally covered in snow sort of as
hiking and mountain biking trails during
the summer months stave Spielman is a
former Swiss banker turned professional
mountain bike guys he brings groups of
all ages up here but this isn't a sport
for the faint of heart
as keep coms trails there are varying
degrees of trails here from rocky too
difficult to man-made so called flow
trails which everyone can do but you
still have to know how to mountain bike
it's not enough just to be able to ride
a bike like in a city here in India dean
winter sport is king and in summer
mountain biking is gaining as queen's
mountain bike in mamizou queen kite and
windsurfing are also big draws in summer
here on lakes of a planet just seven
kilometers from st. moritz surfers of
all ages and nationalities can put their
mettle to the test on the water
[Music]
frenchman alex panier left his native
France 11 years ago to teach windsurfing
he says the conditions here are better
than anywhere else today though the wind
isn't as strong as usual you think we're
not so far from the beach there aren't
big waves the wind is always present
there are different corners of the lake
where the wind is stronger or even
weaker so here the conditions fit every
level from beginner to professional
[Music]
a visit to st. Moritz would not be
complete without chocolate one of the
oldest and best-known cafes is
conclusively Hanselman located in the
heart of st. Morris's old town it dates
back to 1894 and is a popular gathering
place for both locals and tourists and
this cafe the most popular item is the
nut cake it's famous and lots of
international guests buy it because it's
the specialty of this region in terms of
chocolate we have special pralines or
the truffles without alcohol or some
with alcohol of course we have many
different kinds of chocolates it just
depends on the taste of the customer
[Music]
and there's no better way to top off the
day than with a massage at one of st.
Moritz as luxury hotels there are five
of them within about the four kilometer
radius marinella Negri has been working
as a massage therapist in bad roads
Palace Hotel for five years she's a
specialist in Ayurveda massage we have a
lot of treatment are you especially our
Vedic treatment it is better to do
purifying and detoxifying body of course
st. marqs is fresh Mount water and air
are also great ways to purify the body
and soul and unlike most of the
attractions here these views don't cost
a thing
[Music]
you